bonjour à tous en l'absence
d'informations précises de la part des
autorités soviétiques
il est bien difficile ce matin de se
faire une idée très exact des
conséquences de la catastrophe de la
centrale nucléaire de tchernobyl
une chose est sûre en tout cas c'est le
plus grave accident depuis que des
centrales existent dans le monde
le feu consume le coeur de la centrale
et les responsables de la sécurité sont
pour l'instant incapable de l'arrêter
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
moscou a fait appel à la suède et à
l'allemagne de l'ouest
il y avait au cinéma le syndrome chinois
la réalité dépasse aujourd'hui
l'affection il y a désormais un syndrome
soviétique
hier la télévision moscovite donnait
comme bilan officiel de morts mais les
experts américains par les oeufs de 2000
ce matin information supplémentaire un
radio amateur de la région de kiev
indiqué à à l'un de ses collègues
japonais
la catastrophe a certainement fait des
centaines de morts
mais peut-être beaucoup beaucoup plus le
correspondant soviétique a terminé ainsi
son métal son message qu'ils ont dit
long sur ce qui se passe là-bas le monde
n'a pas idée de ce qu'est cette
catastrophe
aidez nous le point fil des quatre jours
après la catastrophe de la centrale de
tchernobyl près semblable à celle ci un
problème majeur subsiste puisque la
partie en graphite du coeur du réacteur
est toujours en feu les premières
retombées radioactives
certes assez faibles ont été mesurés en
finlande suède danemark pologne et
allemagne
on ne sait pas si des fuites ont encore
lieu mais on peut le supposer puisque de
la fumée s'échappe toujours du rôle du
réacteur si les soviétiques ont demandé
l'aide de la suède et de l'allemagne
fédérale s'est probablement qu'ils ont
du mal à maîtriser les conséquences de
cette catastrophe
la plupart des pays européens ont
demandé des explications aux soviétiques
mais ceux ci ne semblent pas pressés
d'en donner le commentateur de la
télévision de moscou est en tout cas
très laconique
la grande question qui se pose
actuellement concerne les conséquences à
long terme en particulier en ce qui
concerne les populations qui ont été
contaminés
on ne sait pas non plus ce que vont
devenir les cultures de sept régions
d'ukraine le grenier à blé de l'urss
selon les conditions météo actuelles le
dégagements radioactifs sous forme de
nuages ne touchera pas la france mais il
redescend sur l'autriche et la
yougoslavie
voilà donc je sais que l'on peut dire
pour l'instant mais de paris je vous
propose maintenant de retrouver au
téléphone le correspondant de l'agencé
france-presse en union soviétique qui
nous parle de la situation telle qu'on
peut la considérer de là-bas à kiev